- [Mark] What's your name?
- [Bebe] Excuse me?
- [Mark] What is your name?
- [Bebe] My name?
- [Mark] Your name.
- My name, Bebe.
- [Mark] Your name is baby?
- Bebe.
- [Mark] Bebe?
- Yes, and you?
- [Mark] My name is Mark.
- Nice to meet you, Mark.
- [Mark] Nice to meet you, Bebe.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Bebe, I love your outfit.
- Yeah, thank you very much.
- [Mark] You look great.
I'm a photographer.
- Huh?
- [Mark] I am a photographer.
- Yeah?
- [Mark] I would love
to take your photograph.
You're beautiful.
- Oh, thank you very much.
- [Mark] I will pay you $20.
- For what?
How many pictures?
- [Mark] Just, my studio
is here on seventh street.
You know, Rebecca?
- Yeah, but I work 20, no.
- [Mark] How much?
- Bebe more.
- 50
- [Mark] 40
- You bring me back?
- [Mark] I'll bring you back.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Come on in.
- [Bebe] Ah, you know Rebecca.
- [Mark] Yeah.
I photographed Rebecca
and last night I photographed Corina.
- [Bebe] Yeah?
- [Mark] You know, Corina?
- [Bebe] Who's Corina?
- [Mark] I'll show you Corina.
- [Mark] Bebe, where are you from?
- I am from Mexico.
- [Mark] Mexico, what city in Mexico?
- Guadalajara.
- [Mark] Guadalajara.
And how long have you
been in the United States?
- About 15 years.
- [Mark] 15 years.
- Yes.
- [Mark] So you're out
there on the street.
It's early in the morning.
What, what time did you get here?
- What time?
Excuse me?
- [Mark] What time?
Four in the morning?
Three in the morning?
- Usually, four to seven.
- [Mark] 4 to 7:00 AM.
On Friday, Saturday, Sunday?
- Only weekends.
- [Mark] Only weekends?
- [Bebe] Yes.
- [Mark] Well, I love what
you're wearing tonight.
I love your beautiful boots.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You're very stylish.
- Oh, thank you.
- [Mark] I think you're the
best dressed girl out there
on the street tonight.
- Oh, thank you.
- [Mark] So you're a woman now.
Beautiful woman.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] When did you become a woman?
- About 10 years.
- [Mark] 10 years ago?
- 10 years ago.
- [Mark] And you have beautiful breasts.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] And do you have
everything taken care of?
- For now, yes.
I hope to
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
So some of the girls have
had more surgery than others?
- Yes, yes.
- [Mark] And the men that you pick up.
They like that you have everything?
It's all something for everything.
- Sometimes they ask me
for something you know.
Different.
For money it's okay.
- [Mark] And where do you go with the men?
You go to the car
or you go to your apartment or you go?
- Usually, my car.
His car.
Sometimes in like apartment.
- [Mark] Where's your apartment?
- I live about four
blocks from (indistinct).
- [Mark] For what?
- Four blocks from (instinct).
- [Mark] Oh, you're very close.
- Yes, I'm very close.
- [Mark] That makes it easy.
And do your parents, how do
your parents feel about this?
Do they know that you're a woman?
- They know about, for now they
do not know what I am doing.
- [Mark] Oh, no, of course not.
Yeah. No, I don't expect
them to know that.
But just when you go home
for visits to Guadalajara
you're dressed like a woman?
- Yes I go home, I wear you
know pants or long dress
Something different.
- [Mark] And they're okay?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's good.
That's nice.
So what advice would you give
somebody who's looking to get
into this line of work?
- The girls?
- A young girl who wants to do this.
Any advice?
Be careful.
- Yes, yes, yes, yes.
- [Mark] Carry a gun.
- If new generations you know
my advice is for now it's okay.
Because they, police is a little.
- [Mark] They let you go.
- Yes, before in the 90s.
- [Mark] They throw you in jail.
- Five years ago, a lot of
problems with the police.
But for now, it's okay.
- [Mark] It's okay.
How many times have you been in jail?
- About three times.
- [Mark] Three times.
- Three times.
- [Mark] That's how bad.
It's for one night.
Two nights?
- Yeah, only for hours.
- [Mark] For hours?
- 'Cause my friend paid
- [Mark] Bail.
- Bail.
- [Mark] And you get out.
Good for you.
So look at you.
Yeah, but your, your beautiful boots.
You got a gold.
It's a gold lamé.
Little jacket.
Oh my gosh.
Look at those.
Those are beautiful.
When did you have these done?
- It's hormones.
- [Mark] That's all hormones?
- Uh, huh.
- [Mark] You're kidding me.
- No, it's hormones.
- [Mark] Those are hormones.
- Uh, huh.
- [Mark] Oh my gosh.
Yeah, they're beautiful.
- Yes.
- [Mark] That's all hormones?
- [Mark] Wow!
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I thought it was plastic surgery.
- No, no, no, no, hormones.
- [Mark] And the men like
your breasts, of course?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And when you, when
you have sex with the men
what kind of stuff do they end up wanting?
- They like it.
- [Mark] They probably want
whatever they can get, right?
- Uh, huh.
- What kind of men do you pick up?
Black men?
White men, Hispanic, Chinese, everything?
- Everything
- [Mark] Everything.
- Everything.
The most is Hispanic.
- [Mark] Mostly Hispanic?
Tell me a crazy story.
Tell me something cool.
- Crazy story with a man.
They like to, okay.
I want to, I want to put your dress.
I want to put your dress.
- [Mark] He wants to wear your clothes?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Wow.
So, he wants to be a woman too.
- Yes.
Take me a picture.
Take my picture with you.
- [Mark] Oh, he wants a
picture taken with you.
- Yes, but in that case I go to my place.
I want to dress with my own clothes.
- [Mark] Right.
- Yes.
- [Mark] What's the most
you made in one night?
- Ah, about four or five.
- [Mark] Four or five hundred?
- Uh, huh.
- [Mark] Nice.
- But regularly it's 250.
- [Mark] Excellent.
- [Bebe] Thank you.
- [Mark] You're lovely.
Thank you so much.
- [Bebe] Okay, bye.
Thank you.